11h ce matin les gendarmes mobiles des
loges les gilet jaune postéraro point de
vesoul provoquant stupeur et
incompréhension chez ces mêmes gillet
qui quelques heures auparavant s'étaient
réunis pour cette nouvelle journée
d'action on ne fait rien on n'a pas
d'armes mais ce viennent-ils son casque
et ils ont des matraques ils ont leur
bouclier alors que nous on n'a rien on
est simple citoyen et voilà on se
dégager comme ça une grenade lacrymogène
un recours aux forces de l'ordre
justifiée par le fait que la
manifestation n'était pas déclarée
c'est ce que précise la préfecture de
haute saône dans un communiqué préfet et
procureurs du même département qui ont
tenu à rappeler les règles
le message est clair vous pouvez
manifester mais aussi lors de billets il
ya aussi la sécurité la liberté de
circuler notamment pour accéder aux
commerces ou à son travail
les personnes qui continuent aujourd'hui
à bloquer des ronds-points des
carrefours des années circulation se
mettent hors la loi ce sont des
comportements qui sont inadmissibles et
qu'ils doivent être sanctionnés
application donc concrète de ces mesures
l'organisatrice de la manifestation a
été conduite au commissariat de vesoul
dehors légers les jaunes l'attend pour
la soutenir
quelques minutes plus tard elle ressort
de son audition sur moi
oui ça continue je pense que ça va
continuer de plus belle
et peut-être plus fort les gendarmes
mobiles qui se positionne à nouveau
cette fois un autre rond-point reprendre
la vaugine de l'autre côté de la rocade
re la quatre voies de vesoul les gilet
jaune rejoints par des tracteurs
s'organisent pour poursuivre la journée
avec en tête les images du matin par un
autre groupe peut-être dans les cinémas
un départ s'organise avec les tracteurs
dans les rues de vesoul à la préfecture
impossible de passer les gendarmes
mobiles bloquent la rue d'égée les
jeunes toujours en mouvement tout au
long de cet après midi donc on est
vraiment dans dans cette ambiance du jeu
du chat et de la souris avec les forces
de l'ordre
des gilets jaunes mobile qui tout au
long de l'après midi auront continué ce
jeu du chat et de la souris pendant
l'instant quatre tracteurs seront même
bloqué par les gendarmes mobiles mais
ils pourront repartir une quatrième
journée d'action sous tension ce mardi à
vesoul